♪
♪♪
, W WILL PUT 30 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK AND SEE HOW MANY
PUTTS YOU CAN MAKE.
THREE, TWO, ONE.
>> THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> TEN SECONDS LEFT.
>> 80,000 MEALS.
PHIL'S READY FOR THIS.
>> WOW.
>> 150,000 MEALS, PHIL.
>> PHIL, I KNOW YOU MADE 15.
DECENT.
NOT THAT GOOD.
LET'S SEE IF I DO A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
YOU READY?
♪
>> YOU WERE SHORT?
COME ON.
HOW MANY WAS THAT?
DO YOU EVEN KNOW?
DOES ANYBODY KNOW?
ROLL THAT BACK AND IN EDITING,
IT WILL BE 16.
BRYSON, YOU'RE UP.
>> PHIL MICKELSON MADE 15 PUTTS
IN 30 SECONDS.
LET'S
LETS SEE IF I CAN DO BETTER.
WHAT WAS THAT?
NINE?
OH, I SUCK.
♪
>> 30 SECONDS.
TEN-FOOT PUTTS.
I GOT A GRAND ON IT.
>> THIS IS GOLF?
>> THIS IS SPORTS.
PROVE IT.
YOU WILL NOT HIT ONE PUTT FROM
TEN FEET.
>> THREE, TWO, ONE.
>> OH, GOSH.
>> OH!
>> THERE IT IS!
YEAH!
>> THAT'S THE LAST ONE.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS ISN'T A SPORT.
>> CAN I HAVE MY PUTTER BACK?
♪
>> 100 BUCKS.
BRYSON HIT NINE.
PHIL HIT 15.
>> 30 SECONDS.
>> ANOTHER 100?
>> PHIL USED TO DO THIS FOR A
LIVING.
>> HOLD IT.
OH!
>> THREE.
FOUR.
FIVE.
SIX.
YEAH.
>> GET THEM OUT.
>> SIX.
>> ONE.
TWO.
>> HE'S GOT THAT GOLDEN.
>> THREE.
FOUR.
FIVE.
SIX.
>> COME ON.
>> SEVEN.
>> HE'S GOT IT.
>> WOW.
>> FIVE, SIX, SEVEN.
THERE IT IS.
>> NINE.
♪
>> JOIN THE MATCH ALUMS.
WHAT IS IT LIKE?
>> IT IS AWESOME.
THE GUYS COME BEFORE ME.
IT'S BEEN COOL TO SEE.
FUN TO WATCH.
I'M EXCITED TO BE PART OF IT.
>> OKAY.
I'LL NAME MATCH PARTICIPANTS AND
YOU GIVE ME THE ONE WORD THAT
COMES TO MIND.
READY?
>> YEAH.
>> PHIL MICKELSON.
>> LEFTY.
>> TIGER WOODS.
>> WINNER.
>> PEYTON MANNING.
>> FOREHEAD.
>> TOM BRADY.
>> G.O.A.T.
>> CHARLES.
>> AWFUL SWING.
>> CURRY.
>> DOWNTOWN.
>> AARON RODGERS.
>> DRY HUMOR.
>> BRYSON.
>> AWFUL.
AWFUL.
AWF
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE HITTING ON
TOP.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> WHY IS HE SMILING?
HIT HIM RIGHT IN HIS VENEERS.
BRYSON HERE, B/R LIVE.
COME ECONOMCHECK IT OUT.
>> WE'LL HEAD UP TO THE HOTEL
AND UP TO THE 60th FLOOR.
>> 60th?
>> WE DOING SOMETHING NO ONE HAS
DONE BEFORE.
YOU WILL BE EXCITED AND
INTERESTED IN THE TARGET ARE YOU
ABO
ABOUT TO HIT.
>> HOW YOU DOING?
>> 60th FLOOR ROOFTOP.
SEE YOU UP THERE.
>> BRYSON, COME ON OUT HERE.
>> ALL RIGHTY.
>> THIS IS INSANE.
OH, I WOULD HAVE NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD EVER BE UP HERE IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
I'M RIPPING BOMBS OFF HERE.
>> HOW BEAUTIFUL IS THIS?
>> THERE HE IS.
WHY IS HE SMILING?
I'M ABOUT TO HIT HIS FACE.
WHAT IS THE YARDAGE?
521 YARDS.
WITH
WOW.
>> 620 FEET.
>> WHAT IS THE SLOPE ADJUSTMENT?
>> 19 DEGREES WITH THE WIND OF
9.5 MILES AN HOUR.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE PLANE RIGHT
THERE?
>> THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THAN I'VE EVER EXPERIENCED.
>> WELL SHORT.
>> A LITTLE SHORT.
>> YOU THINK?
ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS THE REAL DEAL.
COMING FOR YOU, BROOKS.
THAT WAS HIT HARD.
THIS IS SO MUCH FUN.
HOW FAR SHORT IS THAT?
>> HOW FAR SHORT WAS THAT ONE?
>> 50 YARDS SHORT TO THE RIGHT.
RIGHT BY THE WATER.
>> JUST WAIT, GUYS.
I'M GETTING COMFORTABLE STILL.
NO, JUST DREW IT.
COME ON, BALL.
THAT'S GOT A CHANCE.
>> 20 YARDS SHORT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I SEE IT.
OKAY.
THAT'S HIT SO GOOD.
GOSH DARN IT.
OH.
THAT WAS HIT HARD.
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> SHORT AND LEFT OF THE FAY
Y
FAIRWAY.
>> I KNOW.
I SEE IT.
>> WELL SHORT.
>> THANKS.
OH!
DO YOUR THING, BABY.
IT'S NOT ON HIS NOSE.
IT IS GOING RIGHT FOR HIM.
COME ON.
OH, MY GOSH.
OH, MY GOSH!
>> HALF FOOT SHORT.
>> TWO FEET.
NO EXCUSES.
RIGHT HERE.
RIGHT NOW.
>> SHOT COMING.
>> OH!
STAY ON THE TARGET, BABY.
>> HE HIT THE TARGET.
>> NICE GOING, BABY.
I'M GOING TO HIT ANOTHER ONE.
THAT WAS SICK.
LET'S GO!
ALL RIGHT.
I JUST NAILED BROOKS' BIG HEAD
ON TOP OF THE TARGET.
NOW IT IS TIME TO BEAT HIS BUTT
IN A REAL MATCH.
♪
>>> WHAT, UP, EVERYBODY?
WELCOME TO CAPITAL ONE THE MATCH
BROUGHT TO YOU BY TNT.
WE'RE HERE AT THE PRESS
CONFE
CONFERENCE.
I'M HERE WITH THE COUNTRY CLUB
ADJACENT.
>> YES, SIR.
>> SITTING HERE AT THE END
BARELY HANGING ON.
>> I'M MARK SMALLS.
I FLY THE BALL NO MORE THAN 180
YARDS.
>> TRUE.
I'M BLAKE WEBER.
BROOKS KOEPKA STOLE MY SPOT AT
THE FSU GOLF TEAM.
>> I'M GRIF.
>> I'M JAKE.
SITTING NEXT TO ME IS BECAUSE WE
NEEDED SOMEBODY WITH MORE THAN
FOUR MAJORS ON THE PANEL.
FLOP GOD HIMSELF.
PHIL MICKELSON.
PHIL, YOU ARE HERE TO KEEP THESE
GIE
GUYS IN CHECK.
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR PHIL.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THESE GUYS IN
CHECK.
MAKE SURE THEY DON'T DODGES
QUESTIONS.
THEN THE STARS BRYSON DeCHAMBEAU
AND BROOKS KOEPKA.
THANK YOU, GUYS, FOR LETTING US
TAKE 30 MINUTES OF YOUR LIFE AND
OVERALL MAKE IT BETTER.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> YUP.
>> BEFORE WE GET TO YOU GUYS,
WATCH THE MATCH ON TNT PRESENTED
BY CAPITAL ONE.
IT STARTS AT 4:00 P.M. EASTERN.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING THE PRESS
CONFERENCE, YOU WILL WATCH THE
MATCH.
WHO WATCHES THE PRE-GAME PRESS
CONFERENCE?
>> THAT WOULD BE WEIRD.
>> UNLESS YOU ARE MY MOM.
>> LOVE YOUR MOM.
SHE'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> VERY HOT.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
BROOKS AND BRYSON WILL PLAY 12
HOLES TODAY BECAUSE THEY ATE TOO
MUCH TURKEY LAST NIGHT AND 18 IS
A HUGE ASK.
>> HUGE ASK.
>> ESPECIALLY SINCE I DON'T PLAY
MUCH GOLF ANYWAY.
I DON'T LIKE IT.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> I THOUGHT HE PLAYED MUCH
GOLF.
>> ME AND YOU BOTH.
I'M JUST HERE TO GET PAID.
>> HIS TEETH ARE SO WHITE, I'M
GETTING SUNBURNED RY E
ED R?
WHAT DO YOU USE ON YOUR TEETH?
>> THEY ARE FAKE.
>> THEY'RE VENEERS.
>> LET'S NOT DRAW ATTENTION.
IT IS BROADCAST ON THE INTERNET.
>> YOU GUYS WILL BE ASKING THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WRITE IN THAT
WE RELAY TO THESE GUYS.
DROP QUESTIONS IN THE CHAT AND
IF WE PICK YOUR QUESTION ON THAT
SPOT, YOU JUST WON A HOODIE.
MARK SMALLS IS ROCK Y
ING THE
HOODIE.
>> YOU LOOK ALMOST AS COOL AS
MARK.
>> YOU GOT STUFF ON THE SLEEVES.
I'M 80 POUNDS.
I'M COLD.
>> THAT IS A LARGE.
IT WON'T FIT ANY OF THE BIG BOYS
HERE.
THAT'S A GOOD SIZE.
>> LET'S GET INTO IT.
ENOUGH WORDS OUT OF MY MOUTH.
>> LET'S GET INTO THE FIRST
QUESTION.
FROM LOU.
3255.
THIS IS FOR BOTH OF YOU.
SAY SOMETHING NICE ABOUT THE
OTHER PERSON.
>> HE'S GOT GREAT TEETH.
>> OWE, TH, I AGREE.
LOOK AT HIS FACE.
THIS IS A HARD ONE.
>> VERY HARD.
I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE IT
OUT.
>> COME ON.
YOU HAVE TO SAY SOMETHING.
>> I'M SPEECHLESS.
FIRST TIME WITH I MICROPHONE IN
FRONT OF MY FACE.
I'M SPEECHLESS.
I HAVE TO SAY.
>> WOW.
>> I STILL CAN'T THINK.
>> THE BLOOD IS BOILING.
>> IF YOU WANT TO MENTION HE HAS
BETTER ABS THERE YOU.
>> HE HAS BETTER ABS THAN ME.
THANKS FOR THE SUGGESTION.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE
PIC.
>> MY BOYS SENT THAT THIS
MORNING.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO
OILS HIM UP.
>> THAT WAS A NICE THING FOR YOU
TO SAY, BRYSON.
I'LL CALL YOU BRYSIE.
>> GO FOR IT.
THAT WASN'T A QUESTION, WHOEVER
SAID.
IT.
>> SHOUT OUT TO LOU 3255.
>> DISAPPOINDISAPPOINTED.
>> BRYSON, WE ACTUALLY MET
BEFORE.
WE WANTED TO SHOW YOU THE MOMENT
THAT WE MET.
IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL MOMENT.
IF YOU WANT TO PLAY THAT CLIP,
GUYS.
VERY IMPORTANT.
>> LIKE A CAN OF SPAM.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE YOU ARE AFRAID
TO GET OFF CREATINE.
>> DO YOU USE WHEN YOU PAID CASH
FOR YOUR HOME?
>> YOU LOVE THIS SHOW IF YOUR
ROLEX AND BENTLEY.
>> DID ROLLS ROYCE PASS?
>> OKAY.
>> GO BROOKSY.
>> HE DOESN'T WORKOUT.
HE HAS A WAY BETTER PHYSIQUE.
>> AGGRESSIVE ON THAT ONE.
>> THANK GOD THEY DON'T.
>> LITERALLY.
>> I MET BRYSON AND I
IMMEDIATELY THOUGHT WE HAD
IMMEDIATE CHEMISTRY.
THIS GUY HITS HIS DRIVES LIKE HE
IS MAD AT HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND AND
INSECURE AND WORKS OUT TOO MUCH
AND BETTER THAN THE AVERAGE TOUR
PRO.
THAT IS MY GUY THERE.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> YOU ARE A CUTE COUPLE.
THIS IS A QUESTION FROM BUNDLE.
WHICH CLUB WOULD YOU MAKE THE
OTHER GUY PLAY WITH?
>> HIS DRIVER.
HE HITS IT, RIGHT?
MAKE HIM PLAY WITH IT.
>> MAYBE THE PROTOTYPE IN PLAY.
>> OKAY.
>> I WOULD PROBABLY HAVE HIM HIT
HIS OLD NIKE CLUBS.
>> YOU HAVE THE SQUARE SUMO?
>> THAT'S OLD SCHOOL.
I DON'T THINK WE WERE BORN THEN.
>> I WAS.
>> BRYSON, ARE YOU WEARING IRON
COVERS ON YOUR TEETH?
>> EXACTLY.
INVISILIGN.
I'M TRYING TO GO THE NATURAL
ROUTE THAN THE VENEER ROUTE.
>> MORE NATURAL.
>> I LIKE TO SEE BROOKS PLAY
WITH HIS DRIVER, TOO.
BY THE WAY, IT WAS NICE FOR YOU
TO TEAM UP WITH THE NON-PROFIT
ORGANIZATION SRXION.
I HOPE WE HAVE SRXION PEOPLE
HERE TODAY.
>> MARK, WE HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION?
>> MY PHONE IS ON LOW POWER
MODE.
I LIVE MY LIFE ON 13% BATTERY.
LET'S GO WITH @NOBREAD, IF YOU
PUNCH YOURSELF AND IT HURTS, ARE
YOU STRONG OR ARE YOU WEAK?
>> WELL, I WOULD SAY YOU'RE
BOTH.
PHIL DOES IT ALL THE TIME.
>> PHIL, YOU'RE HERE?
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET IN THE
MIDDLE.
HE IS SUCH A STRONG INDIVIDUAL.
NOTHING CAN BREAK PHIL.
I TRIED FOR YEARS TO GET INTO
HIS HEAD.
IT BOUNCES RIGHT OFF.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
>> MAYBE TAKE OUT ONE OF THE 17
CHEMICALS IN HIS COFFEE.
>> I'M THE ONLY ONE HERE WHO HAS
WON A MAJOR THIS YEAR.
>> SHUTS IT DOWN.
>> ALSO, HE IS THE ONLY ONE HERE
WHO BEAT UP GERIATRICS ON THE
CHAMPIONS TOUR.
>> IT'S NOT FAIR.
>> AT 50 YEARS OLD ON THE
HARDEST GOAL COURSE IN AMERICA.
SHOUTOUT TO PHIL.
>> IMPRESSIVE.
PLEASE, GET BACK TO THOSE TWO.
I WANT TO HEAR THEM GET AT IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
STRONG OR WEAK IF YOU PUNCH
YOURSELF AND IT HURTS.
BROOKS?
>> STRONG.
I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU PUNCHING
YOURSELF FOR?
>> YOU JUST LOST A MAJOR.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE PUNCHING
YOURSELF.
>> NO BREAD, NO CHEESE.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT,
PHIL?
>> TRUE.
I HAD A LOT OF LOSSES.
I MEAN, NOT IN MAY.
A LOT OF LOSSES.
>> BOTH OF YOU TO TIGER.
THAT GUY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HE'S COMING
BACK.
>> THIS QUESTION IS FROM PAT
PEPPERONI.
>> NOT A REAL PERSON.
>> HOW MUCH DO YOU GUYS PEBENCH?
>> YOU WANT KNOW GO FIRST?
275.
THAT'S ALL I GOT.
>> WOW.
>> HUGE.
>> HUGE FOR A GOLFER.
>> NOT THAT MUCH.
BENCH PRESSING DOESN'T CREATE
LONG DRIVES.
>> WHAT DOES?
>> SPEED.
>> WHAT MUSCLE?
>> WHAT WORKOUT SHOULD WE DO?
>> EVERYTHING OWE TROTATIONAL.
DISC, SLEDGEHAMMER.
IT WILL BE ON MY YOUTUBE PAGE IN
A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
>> PHIL, DO YOU THROW
SLEDGEHAMMERS TO WIN MAJORS?
>> YES.
>> WITH YOUR CALVES?
>> ONLY WITH HIS HALVES.
>> WHAT WAS THE QUESTION?
>> HOW MUCH DO YOU BENCH?
>> DO YOU HAVE A HANGOVER FROM
TACO BELL?
>> STUCK ON THAT TURKEY, BRO.
>> I BET BROOKS COULD GET OLD
SCHOOL MEXICAN PIZZAS FROM THEM.
>> THEY TOOK IT OFF THE MENU.
>> SO RUDE.
>> WHAT DID YOU HAVE FOR
BREAKFAST?
>> BREAKFAST BURRITO.
ROOM SERVICE IS SOLID.
GOOD SPOT.
>> I'M GOOD TO GET ONE MYSELF.
>> 315.
>> WOW.
HE'S GOT YOU.
>> MARK, THAT'S PRETTY SIMILAR.
>> YOU GUYS ARE ABOUT THE SAME.
>> I THOUGHT THE SAME THING WHEN
I WALKED ON STAINIGE.
>> BEFORE WE GET TO ANOTHER FAN
SUBMITTED QUESTION, WE HAVE A
VIDEO QUESTION FROM ONE OF THE
GREATEST ATHLETES IN THE GAME.
WHEN I SAID ATHLETE, I PUT
QUOTES IN MY HEAD.
TAKE IT AWAY, SIR CHARLES.
>> BRYSON, THIS IS FORMER CHAMP
CHARLES BARKLEY ASKING YOU A
QUESTION.
HOW DO YOU PLAN ON GETTING IN
BROOKS' HEAD?
MY FAVORITE TECHNIQUE IS A LOT
OF TRASH TALK, BUT WHAT IS GOING
TO BE YOUR TECHNIQUE TO GET IN
HIS HEAD?
>> I THINK FOR ME IT WILL BE
WHEN THERE IS A WALMART BETWEEN
OUR GOLF BALLS THAT MAY GET TO
HIM A LITTLE BIT.
BEING 60 YARDS PAST HYMNIM ON A
COUPLE OF YARDS IS MY STRATEGY.
LIKE THIS.
I LIKE THAT.
>> SWEET.
>> COOL.
>> BROOKS DOESN'T CARE.
BUT SECRETLY DOES.
>> THAT WAS A FOUR SECOND
QUESTION THAT TURNED INTO 45.
HE PLAYED FOOTBALL INSTEAD OF
BASKETBALL.
>> THEY SAY THAT BASKETBALL IS A
CONTACT SPORT, BUT FOOTBALL IS A
COLLISION SPORT.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING.
>> NEXT QUESTION FROM FAULKENER.
I DID NOT MAKE THIS UP.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO MAKE
HIM LOSE HIS CAREER BEFORE IT
STARTS?
>> SUSPICIOUS.
>> A HUGE MOMENT FOR US AND
PHIL.
>> PHIL.
>> I DON'T THINK PHIL'S
CONTRACTED TO SAY MORE THAN
SEVEN WORDS THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE.
>> QUIET DOWN, PHIL.
>> WHO WOULD WIN IN A BOXING
MATCH?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
PUT THE GLOVES ON FOR THE 13th
HOLE?
>> WOULD YOU GUYS FIGHT JAKE
PAUL FOR ENOUGH MONEY?
WOULD YOU FIGHT JAKE PAUL IF YOU
COULD WIN ANOTHER MAJOR?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> THAT'S A QUICK YEAH.
>> GET YOUR ASS BEAT, BUT YEAH.
>> WOULD YOU FIGHT JAKE PAUL,
BRYSON?
>> LOOK, IF IT PAID ENOUGH, YES,
I WOULD.
THAT'S THE ANSWER.
>> THE GAME OF GOLF.
IT IS ALL ABOUT MONEY.
LOVE THAT ENERGY.
>> OKAY.
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE FROM KATIE.
HOW MANY HOLES DOES A STRAW
HAVE?
PHILOSOPHY QUESTION.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> LITERALLY.
>> WHAT ARE THESE QUESTIONS?
>> ASK THE FANS.
WE DIDN'T WRITE THEM.
>> THE PERSON SAID HOW MANY
HOLES DOES THE STRAW HAVE GETS A
SWEAT
SWEATSHIRT?
>> YEAH.
>> WE ARE GETTING PAID $88
$8
HOUR TO BE HERE.
HOW MANY HOLES DOES A STRAW
HAVE?
>> THE QUESTION WAS DIRECTED AT
YOU TWO.
>> PHIL ACTED LIKE HE IS IN AN
INTERROGATION ROOM.
>> WHY DOES A MANHOLE -- WHY IS
IT CIRCULAR AND NOT SQUARE?
>> THAT'S EASY.
>> SO IT DOESN'T FALL IN ON I
ITSELF.
>> WHY CAN YOU NOT ANSWER HOW
MANY HOLES A STRAW HAS?
THAT'S WHY WE NEEDED PHIL.
>> SO IT ONLY TOOK 13 MINUTES
FOR BRYSON TO MENTION GOOD
EVENING GEOMETRY.
>> THAT'S ALL THE I KNOW.
>> I GOT A QUESTION.
THIS ONE IS DOES YOUR PHONE
STILL HAVE A BATTERY?
>> WE'RE AT 7
%.
SWITCHED TO LOW POWER MODE.
>> ME BEING A CHEMICAL GUY
MYSELF, THIS ONE IS COMING IN
FROM T. PRICE.
WHAT DOES CREATINE TASTE LIKE ON
BREAKFAST CEREAL?
>> EVERYBODY IS A COMEDIAN?
>> THAT IS A GOOD ONE.
THAT GOT LAUGHS FROM THE CROWD.
>> BOTH OF YOU.
>> I CAN ANSWER THAT ONE.
>> OKAY.
WE HAVE UNFLAVORED.
VANILLA AND CHOCOLATE.
THEY'RE ALL DELICIOUS.
>> DO YOU PUT IT IN YOUR COFFEE?
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
>> HE WAS THINKING ABOUT THAT.
OH, NO.
I'M WINNING MAJORS AT 50.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS IN
THE COFFEE RIGHT THERE.
HERE WE GO.
>> AND QBD SAYS BESIDES GOLF,
WHAT SPORT COULD YOU BEAT EACH
OTHER AT?
>> OH, TENNIS?
YOU LIKE TENNIS?
>> I GIVE HIM TENNIS.
NO CHANCE.
PING PONG.
I WATCHED HIM PLAY PING PONG AT
THE RYDER CUP.
>> HE WOULD BEAT ME AT
BASKETBALL.
>> THESE GUYS LIKE EACH OTHER.
>> REAL SPORTS.
YEAH.
>> I THINK BRYSON COULD BEAT YOU
ON "FORTNIGHT."
>> I NEVER PLAYED IT.
HE HAS THE ADVANTAGE.
>> THAT'S A GOOD ANSWER.
WHO IS A BETTER ARTIST OUT OF
BOTH OF YOU?
>> YOU JUST GAVE THAT RIGHT
AWAY.
>> I'LL GIVE IT TO HIM.
NOT ME.
>> I DID A DRAWING BACK IN MY
HIGH SCHOOL YEARS.
>> DID YOU?
YOU WILL BE DRAWING NFTs?
>> NFTs.
>> I FEEL BROOKS COULD DRAW TACO
BELL.
YOU COULD IF YOU PUT YOUR MIND
TO IT.
>> I BET BROOKS COULD DRAW A
PERFECT CIRCLE ON A CHALK BOARD.
>> ANATOMICALLY CORRECT.
>> BIG BRIDGESTONE.
I COULD SEE THAT.
>> WHAT ELSE YOU GOT?
>> THE NEXT QUESTION IS COMING
FROM ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS
GOLFERS OF ALL TIME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, MICHELLE
WIE.
>> HEY, BROOKS, WOULD YOU GIVE
UP ONE OF THE MAJOR WINS IF YOU
TOLD YOU THAT YOU NEVER WOULD
HAVE TO PLAY WITH BRYSON
DeCHAMBEAU EVER AGAIN?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> I DON'T CARE ABOUT PLAYING
WITH HIM.
I LIKE MY MAJORS.
THEY'RE PRETTY GOOD.
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> I COULD CARE LESS WHO I PLAY
WITH.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> IF YOU LOSE TO BRYSON TODAY,
YOU MAY NEVER WIN ANOTHER MAJOR?
>> I'LL BE ALL RIGHT.
>> IF YOU THINK THEY GOT RID OF
THE U.S. OPEN, YOU WOULD NEVER
PLAY GOLF AGAIN?
>> NO.
>> HE'S LIKE ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> I'M ALL RIGHT.
>> I'LL BE FINE.
NOTHING MATTERS.
I'M HERE TO WIN.
>> YEAH.
I HAVE A LOT OF MONEY ON BRYSON
TODAY.
I NEED YOU TO SHOW UP.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU FEEL.
WHO IS DEFINITELY -- DO YOU FEEL
SOMEONE IS BETTER?
>> DO YOU FEEL THERE IS AN
ADVANTAGE?
>> HAVE YOU SEEN HOW I HAVE BEEN
PLAYING LATELY?
I'M PLAYING PRETTY BAD.
TO BE HONEST.
>> MISSED CUTS AND NOT GIVING
HIM THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> WE H
CAN GO P FURTHER BACK N
THAT.
>> DID YOU HAVE INJURIES?
>> I'M NOT USING THAT AN EXCUSE.
I'M PLAYING BAD.
>> IT'S 12 HOLES.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
>> WHY DID THEY CHOOSE 12 HOLES?
YOU GUYS WOULD BE TOO EXHAUSTED?
>> THEY WANTED TO GIVE BRYSON TO
BEAT HIS SCORE ON THE BACK NINE
AT THE U.S. OPEN.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M GETTING WORD FROM THE
DIRECTOR.
THAT WAS A LITTLE TOO MEAN.
>> IT'S GOOD.
I'M COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
I RECOGNIZE THAT STUFF HAPPENS.
WHEN YOU MISS CUTS, YOU HAVE TO
SOME SOME FIRE POWER.
>> BAD LUCK.
>> BRYSON, WHEN I TOLD YOU THAT
WE WOULD PLAY THE VIDEO FROM
MICHELLE WIE, THAT IT WAS THE
TIKTOK.
>> SHE SAID YOU HAVE TO DO IT.
>> FINE.
>> OKAY.
>> OH, NO.
>> I LOVE TO SEE IT.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO GET THAT
PLAYER IMPACT MONEY.
>> PIP.
LET'S GO.
>> I HATE THIS.
I HATE WE HAVE TO WATCH THIS
AGAIN.
>> THIS IS GREAT.
>> BROOKS, HOW WOULD YOU RATE MY
DANCE MOVES?
>> OH, GOSH.
>> LET'S SEE IT.
♪
THAT LONESOME FEELING ♪
♪ WHOLE WORLD ♪
>> THIS IS THE WORST VERSION OF
THE PULP FICTION.
>> I LOVE BRYSON THAT HE CALLS
IT OUT.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT BRYSON
IS THAT HE GETS IT.
HE IS TROLLING ALL OF US.
PEOPLE THINK HE IS THE DUDE.
PHYSICS GUYS WITH ASBERGERS.
BRYSON KNOWS WHAT HE IS DOING.
>> AS LONG AS YOU CALLED IT OUT.
PLEASE.
>> THAT WAS THE POINT.
>> JUST LIKE BROOKS ACTS LIKE HE
DOESN'T CARE.
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GUYS, THANK YOU FOR SENDING IN
QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE TEN MINUTES LEFT.
YOU HAVE TIME TO DROP QUESTIONS
IN THE CHAT.
WE WILL ASK ONE MORE QUESTION.
WE WILL PICK THE BEST ONE OF THE
DAY AND IFIT IS YOUR QUESTION,
YOU WIN $500.
PHIL, YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT YOU
SPEND ON BREAKFAST?
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT, I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE A NICE TIME TO ASK A
QUESTION TO EACH OTHER.
IF NOT, PHIL, MAYBE IF YOU HAVE
A QUESTION FOR THESE GUYS.
THIS IS YOUR MOMENT.
>> READ THAT ONE OFF.
WHAT DO YOU GOT FOR US?
>> THE WHOLE THING IS FOR YOU TO
ASK A QUESTION.
>> I'M OUT OF WORDS.
I'M TAPPED OUT.
>> PHIL, ARE YOU HERE RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M ENJOYING THIS.
I'M ENJOYING THIS.
I'M JUST PROCESSING WHAT I SAW
ON THE DANCE THING.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE WORLD OF
YOU.
I THINK A LITTLE BIT LESS NOW,
THAT'S ALL.
>> THAT'S ALL I WAS HOPING FOR.
>> IT WAS CUED.
IT WAS -- DISAPPOINTING THOUGH.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> I DON'T GET IT.
>> I LOVE MICHELLE WIE.
SHE TOLD ME I HAD TO DO IT.
WHATEVER.
>> IT'S -- IT'S NOT YOU IN A
THONG.
>> I REMEMBER -- ON YOUR OWN
INSTAGRAM FEED.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK THE WORLD OF BOTH OF
YOU.
A LITTLE BIT LESS.
>> HOW MANY FOLLOWERS DID YOU
LOSE?
>> 1,000.
NOT BAD.
>> YOU ARE PROMOTING THE
YOUTUBE.
ARE YOU PROMOTING THE ONLY FANS
AS WELL?
>> BROOKS, WHAT GOT YOU TO DO
THAT PARTICULAR POST?
>> TOO MANY DRINKS.
WHEN YOU ARE IN THE MALDIVES,
YOU ARE DRINKING A LOT.
>> I GET DOING THE PICTURE AND
EVERYTHING.
THEN TO PRESS SEND AND POST IT.
THAT'S WHAT I'M WONDERING.
>> MALDIVES BRINGS IT OUT IN
YOU.
>> IT IS FUNNY.
>> BUTTS ARE FUNNY.
>> YOU HAVE DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES.
YOU THROW OUT THE VIDEO WHEN
YOU'RE DRUNK.
PHIL WILL SIT IN THE PRESS
CONFERENCE AND SAY I DON'T CARE.
I WON THE PGA.
>> ONE MORE QUESTION BEFORE THE
$500 QUESTION.
THIS ONE IS FROM ARMANDO.
WHO HAS THE BIGGER CALVES?
PHIL, PLEASE DON'T ANSWER.
>> MINE ARE NOT THAT BIG.
I'LL BE HONEST.
I DO HAVE TREE TRUNK LEGS,
THOUGH.
THEY'RE NOT GREAT.
I NEED TO GET ON PHIL'S WORKOUT
SCHEDULE.
CAN WE DO A LITTLE SOMETHING?
>> PHIL, CAN YOU BUST THOSE OUT?
>> ONLY FOR YOU.
>> WE CAN'T SEE A LITTLE --
>> OH, MY GOSH.
THROUGH THE PANTS EVEN.
MASSIVE.
>> HE HAS CALVES CLEAVAGE.
>> BROOKS?
>> WE'LL GIVE IT TO BRYSON.
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
BRYSON, OKAY.
WELL DONE ON THE CALVES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
BLAKE, YOU WANT TO READ THE $500
QUESTION?
>> YEAH.
A LOT OF MONEY.
>> THIS QUESTION IS WORTH $500
AS HE SAID.
FROM SCOTT O'DONNELL.
YOUR OPPONENT IS LINING UP A
PUTT TO WIN THE MATCH.
YOU GET TO WHISPER ONE THING IN
THEIR EAR TO BREAK HIS
CONCENTRATION.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> OH, THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> RIGHT?
THIS IS THE FIRST GOOD QUESTION.
I'M GLAD THEY WON THE MONEY.
>> BROOKSY SEEMS TO BUG HIM A
LOT.
>> THAT GETS ME QUITE A BIT.
>> YOU HAD TO GO TO THE TOUR TO
GET THEM TO STOP SAYING THAT.
THAT BUGGED HIM A LOT.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> I KNOW WHAT I WOULD DO.
>> INSIGHTFUL STUFF.
>> SIMPLE.
I WOULD BE WALKING ON THE CART
PATH WITH SPIKES.
>> HE WOULDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
YOUR CLEATS DO THE TALKING.
>> THE SPIKES DROWN OUT THE
SOUND OF HIS MOUTH.
>> THEY'RE FINE.
THEY ARE FINE.
THE SPIKES DON'T BUG ME.
>> WOULD YOU --
>> I ENJOYED HEARING THE SPIKES.
>> WOULD YOU SAY --
>> NOT DURING THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
>> WOULD YOU SAY THAT WAS THE
MOMENT THAT SPARKED THE BEEF?
>> WHAT WAS THE MOMENT?
>> THAT SEEMED LIKE TO US
OUTS
OUTSIDERS, WHAT WAS IT?
>> THAT KICKED IT ALL OFF.
THE HIGHER GEAR OF WHAT IT WAS.
I DON'T THINK WE'VE EVER GOTTEN
ALONG OR LIKED EACH OTHER.
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
THAT SENT IT INTO A LITTLE
OVERDRIVE.
>> WHY WAS THERE TENSION BEFORE?
I WARRANNT TO BE THE BUFFEST GU
TOUR?
WHERE DID THAT START?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
WE PLAYED THE MASTERS IN 2015.
WE PLAYED IN THE AMATEUR.
WHATEVER IT WAS.
THERE IS NOT MUCH IN COMMON.
JUST BE FLAT OUT HONEST.
>> A LOT IN COMMON.
I'M SHOCKED.
>> TWO ALPHAS THAT DON'T GET
ALONG.
>> EXACTLY.
>> WOULD YOU WRITE TRACKS
AGAINST EACH OTHER?
>> A LITTLE EXTRA PIP?
>> CRINGE, I COULD SEE YOU
DROPPING 16.
>> AND PHIL, THE WISE PHIL, DO
YOU HAVE ANY ADVICE FOR THEM AND
REST OF THEIR CAREERS?
>> YOU LIKE HOW HE THREW IN
WISE?
AS OPPOSED TO SAYING OLD.
>> IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, I LIKE
AND RESPECT BOTH OF THEM VERY
MUCH.
THEY DO THINGS VERY DIFFERENTLY.
YET, BOTH WAYS ARE VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
I HOPE TODAY DURING THE MATCH
WE'RE ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS AND
SEE A LITTLE BIT INSIDE HOW
THEIR MIND WORKS BECAUSE THEY
BOTH WORK SO DIFFERENTLY AND YET
ARE BOTH DRIVEN TO SUCCEED AND
BE THE BEST.
THEY ARE.
THEY ARE TWO OF THE BEST IN THE
WORLD.
THEY CAN PROVIDE INSIGHT AND I'M
HOPING THIS MATCH AND THE
INTIMACY THE MATCH PROVIDED ON
INSIGHT INTO HOW THE CHAMPION
THINKS WILL GIVE THE VIEWER AT
HOME A VIEW OF THEIR GREATNESS
THAT YOU WOULDN'T NORMALLY SEE.
>> WOW.
>> THERE'S A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
>> THAT GETS THE MOST SERIOUS
COMMENT THAT WAS MADE TODAY.
>> EVER.
>> I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION.
WHO DID YOU PUT MONEY ON?
>> YOU CAN'T LEGALLY SAY?
>> AS I -- WHAT I BELIEVE IS
GOING TO HAPPEN AND I BELIEVE
BROOKS WILL GET OFF TO A 1-UP
LEAD IN THE FIRST FEW HOLES AND
I THINK BRYSON WILL WIN THE
MATCH 2 & 1.
>> TUNE IN AT 4:00 P.M. EASTERN.
THIS WAS FUN.
THANK YOU FOR FOBEING HERE.
THANK YOU, PHIL.
MAKE SURE YOU WATCH THE MATCH ON
TNT.
A LOT OF MONEY DONATED TO
CHARITY.
THANK YOU, CAPITAL ONE, FOR
PUTTING THIS ON.
THEY WILL BATTLE IT OUT.
WE HAVE BEEN COUNTRY CLUB
ADJACENT SGR
ADJACENT.
>> FOLLOW US ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
GUYS, ENJOY THE MATCH.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS WAS FANTASTIC.